it's just 6:30 in the morning but the
cooking fire is already going like in
millions of other Ugandan households
grace Bogumil is preparing peanuts for
breakfast her children pitch in
including 21 year old Wilfred he's
training to be an electrician and is the
family's hope for a better future I see
that Wilfred is a good boy
and my hopes are high for him something
big is going to happen here
we'll get electricity and he'll help us
I can feel it the family has no
electricity just a small patch of land
in a few chickens Wilfred is one of five
children and luckily he's got a state
scholarship to support his training it's
true that I bring for them electricity
my special and I'm through easy this
certificate I'm pursuing at the
Institute and I get someone when when
I'm being paid I will at least make sure
that I have done something for them
every morning Wilfred Bouma walks almost
four kilometres to school nothing
unusual in Uganda at the Technical
School young people can train for
various professions such as electrician
or car mechanic the electricity is out
again today so the students make do with
manual tools the sewing machines have
also stopped they need to get the
generator up and running again for the
deputy headmaster it's a familiar
problem
you know our here is not stable the one
is on one day another days off and you
know the support from very far removed
ugly beautiful so the distance is very
long so any instance along the way and I
talked about greed that's why we're
having our unstable up country the power
supply is centrally controlled it's
expensive and in poor condition one
solution is to use local solar panels
but few schools can afford it during
their training the budding electricians
learn all they need to know about
installation Mariam hyungo wants to use
her skills to help her family she's
already installed a solar panel at home
they give us freedom of not buying
peripherals you don't Western aid
sources and there are other things it's
me - one mounted and I feel that let me
go and do this so that I can again that
experience in mounting it electric ovens
are a rarity in Uganda efficient use of
firewood here is a big issue a year ago
with the help of a South Korean Bank in
the Ugandan government this school got a
new oven it uses 60% less firewood than
the old one and requires less work to
operate their new event is the best for
me down fantastic
no smoke no water
I like it very much she's fast in
cooking very fast when you put very
little firewood Justina Coomer from the
Ministry of Energy is visiting the
school she wants similar ovens to be
installed across Uganda some 15,600 in
the countries schools alone
the deputy headmaster shows a Kumu where
she cooked before they got the new oven
I know deforestation is so bad I mean
our rate of the percentage of forests
that we have today in the country stands
at 9%
you know from 36% that we had about 15
years ago so in the last 15 years we've
had a rate of deforestation at about
we've lost about 25 percent of our
forest cover it's so much and if you
look at the root cause of deforestation
it is harvesting wood for energy for
cooking energy because we use wood as
our primary source of energy for cooking
in schools at households in it in
restaurants in all institutions even in
the industries as a source of of process
heat trees are filled everywhere whether
it be for charcoal or clearing large
areas for agricultural land
200 kilometers south of Kampala lies the
new Africa primary school the school
uses a lot of firewood the headmaster
says they can't afford a new oven
Justina Kumu tries to convince the
headmaster to get one she argues that
it's possible for schools to take out
loans with favorable conditions so far
with improved cookstoves with a boat
we've been able to construct more than
100 cook stoves in education
institutions whereby we've been and this
was on a demonstration basis pier by we
just wanted to create awareness about
improved cookstove so we did demos
across the country so that's other
schools within those regions kind
benchmark but the school has already
taken out a loan for solar panels to
provide light in the bathrooms there's
also a light bulb hanging in the
classroom now the result of an
initiative from the school parents and
community
actually actually the government has no
hand so far we are struggling with loans
to put up with buildings like this one
because we can't teach the children when
outside so what we do we go to banks to
get loans and put up classes so that
children Ugandan children are able to
access quality education like Miriam and
younger the young woman who thanks to
her good education as an electrician was
able to install one solar panel on the
roof of her family home her family of 12
hopes there are more to come
you